there's a lot going on and Chris Pratt's
life you know what you're absolutely
right a new lego movie yeah there's that
okay yeah the engagement of course I sat
down with Chris for his first interview
since Katherine Swartz and Egger said
Jurassic yes
in real life congratulations thanks man
I'm a lucky man and ironically this
movie is about building or rebuilding
your life and building the perfect
future how do you see the perfect future
the perfect future you know lots of lots
of kids maybe less time spent working in
more time spent enjoying you know that a
life and I always want to be that guy
who like works to live rather than lives
to work 12 days after announcing his
engagement to Katherine Schwarzenegger
Chris Pratt sounds like a man ready to
really settle down his fiancee actually
worked here at et as a special
correspondent in 2012 we work together
and each into some fantastic so that's
all right yeah this cool Chris's divorce
from Anna Faris was officially finalized
two months ago they share custody of
their six-year-old son Jack who got to
see an early screening Jack loves this
movie love's lego man he lost his mind
News with all his friends at a huge
dance party afterwards they're like dad
can i watch it too he wait we got home
is that dad can we see it lego movie -
right now I was like no you can't use
that get all you could do it on Apple TV
like actually you can't do it just yet
when can I see it oh there was a talking
ice cream cone Chris voices - rolls
emmet brickowski and everyman
construction worker and a new character
rex danger vest thanks for helping me
save the world the lego movie - the
second part is out February 8th it's can
be a challenge creating a sequel that
lives up to the promise of the first
movie I'm glad to say we were able to do
that
listen your kids will love this movie it
is everything you expect when you go to
see a lego movie and then there's a
little something for adults like a movie
[Music]
[Applause]